ask for feedback I think one of the most
important things that you can do in
business is ask her feedback ask your
feedback about your idea about your
vision about how you're executing it I
like to say that you want to make the
big decisions with your heart and the
small ones with your head and the
feedback loop comes in on the head you
need to have a vision for what you want
to do and if people don't like it or
don't agree with it like if there's
still what you want to do then you have
to find a way to do it the heart can
create a world that the head doesn't
know existed the head is the logic is
the reason is that it's the practicality
part of it where the heart is the real
drive for the entrepreneurs for the
innovators to create something that
doesn't exist the Kree something that
hasn't been done before I think too many
people only listen to the feedback and
they let that influence the big
decisions are going to make for me it's
much more do it on the practical level
for how to execute but my vision if you
don't like it I don't care I'm gonna go
off and create it anyway and so how this
relates to my book I wrote the book that
I wanted to write I wrote the book that
I think would have a meaningful impact I
wrote the book that I wish that I had as
a template for my own business just like
I make the videos that I want to see for
myself the practicality for the asking
for feedback comes more Andy if i look
at my youtube channel what do you guys
think I should do next which next top 10
should I add to the video or when asking
for the book it's is it available in
your country do you guys want to have an
audio book right if you didn't want it
out of your book that's okay i'm not i'm
not super attached to the audiobook I
just want to get the message out there
you want an audiobook great you guys
want an e-book great and I've been I've
been pounding it leaving the feedback
let me know what you guys want let me
know where we're letting you down
because I want to pass all that to the
publisher to try to alleviate some of
those concerns and we're making progress
right we have our audio book up we have
the e-book up we're opening up amazon
orders in new countries if there's
something that we still haven't done yet
that you're frustrated with and you
can't order and it's not to your liking
let us know leave in the comments I
will forward it to my publisher and see
what we can get done and that's the
asking for feedback and that's that's
the the head helping with practicality
to execute on the heart the heart is the
book I'm not asking what do you guys
want me to write about I know what I
want to write about I want to get this
out I want to get this into your hands
into your head into your life into your
business and so taking a little step
further I'd like to ask for a little
more feedback one of the things that
we've done obviously is create a landing
page and on that landing page is all the
content around the book that we're using
to sell it from why I wrote the book to
some of the topics in the book from book
observes from people who recommended the
book to the bonus packages all sorts of
different things on that landing page
and we're so in it you know sometimes
you're so in it that sometimes it's hard
to step outside and we're in the zone
now where we need the feedback i'm about
to get ready for the bigger push it's
going to come kind of mid-october is
what they're saying for the timing and
so before that's done I would love to
get your feedback if you guys want to go
check out the landing page let me know
what you think like what speaks to you
what what don't you understand what
needs to be tweaked what needs to be
changed I'm not massively attached to
most of the things on that page my goal
is I want to get this in the hands of a
lot of people because I think you can
really have a tremendous impact on their
lives and on their businesses and so if
you guys have practical feedback to
share I'm asking for it now so if you
guys can go check out the page let me
know what you think it would really mean
a lot to me and just overall your
feedback your support your generosity
has meant a lot to me in building this
channel and I'm excited to continue that
momentum in progress towards the book
okay so let's get to the update into the
questions so as of now we have a hundred
and what do we get 166 pre-ordered books
it still feels really low to me my my
agent is saying that it's it's really
good momentum and maybe I just have
different standards or maybe I'm just
not used to the process it feels like
it's insanely low but I'm still looking
forward to hitting that goal of 3000 and
any support you guys want to land and
either buying copies are recommending it
to friends would really really mean a
lot to me and next week I'll give you
guys
is the next update okay to the questions
first up Stefan Stefan Rudolph do we
have time for growth if we're driving
working out quiet time when the office
emailing down time after work yes we all
have time to grow I agree i think you
make time for the things that are
important to you you don't have extra
time you know entrepreneurs don't just
have days open in their calendar right
you're off hustling you're off trying to
make your dreams happen you're off
trying to make an impact you have trying
to bring in some extra money for your
company the important things in life
have to be scheduled in you have to make
it a priority so growth is important you
know i factor that into my daily routine
so that I'm always absorbing new
information I'm growing I'm learning I'm
trying to get better and I think it's
important part of a daily regimen that
helps make you a better entrepreneur and
you have to find time for next up Steven
Martin guitar evan why don't you just
sell direct to your friends for the
audiobook I get physical sales need
shipping and that's a lot of physical
work the process and post but an eStore
and automatic download link should be
easier to set up and you can earn
without other companies taking a cut
first plus it's even more traffic on
your own site Steven I'm feeling the
love i really appreciate the suggestion
the way that book rights work when
you're working with a big publisher is
they own the rights the only thing I own
is the YouTube rights I negotiated that
out where I own the YouTube rights to my
book being a youtuber feel like there
might be an opportunity to use it there
but the audio book and the e-book and
the physical book they own the rights to
and I'm I'm okay with that too the
reason why I'm doing this is not to try
to make a ton of money by selling the
book and selling the audiobook I really
wanted to get it in people's hands and a
lesson that I try to apply across all my
businesses is I want my suppliers and my
partner's to win too right like if I was
only selling the hard copy book through
the publisher and then I'm selling the
e-book and the audio book by myself in
you know if I'm driving traffic to try
to get those sales going and maybe
that's my incentive now because I'm
making more money here instead of
selling a hard copy I want my publisher
to win like I want my publisher to make
money off of this I want them to think
that this is an important book I want
them to grow and I want to be able to do
more projects either with them or with
other publishers as well and so I'm not
a big fan
I've always cutting out the middleman
and cutting out my suppliers when I can
build a really strong long-term
relationship with them because I would
like to work with them again and it's
not just about the money it's about the
impact and so would that have been
possible maybe but I see it much more as
a short-term play where with what my
goal is to help a billion entrepreneurs
I find that by working with them our
interests are better aligned and they
want to help me more which I'd love to
have next up Jonathan Bubba where do you
get the wall photo I want one yeah I was
having a hard time getting pictures I
wanted something in my office obviously
they're not here at TDS but I want
something in my office that I walked
into and I felt inspired and there was
greatness around me a lot of those
pictures are personal you may not know
most of the people in those pictures
with the measles than me I did the first
one by finding a big red's picture of
Steve Jobs he was the first one is in
some of my old old old videos and the
goal was always to have a line of them
it was one hard to get pictures of a
certain size and then to it was
expensive to get them printed on campus
and really with the help of jason j
reyez fonseka he had some editing tools
to blow up pictures and make them look
good because i'm looking at AP Giannini
you know founder of Bank of America
there's not a lot of high res quality
pictures of him and so Jerry Rice helped
me out with that put in together and we
put them up on the wall I made them
myself is a short answer that's the
biggest size poster you can get printed
I'd staples and we just we just printed
them ourselves and had it shipped and I
was so excited to get them print it off
and put up maybe something to look at
again like there's so many opportunities
to stretch my brand in a lot of
different ways but for now I'm just a
consumer as opposed to being a reseller
of posters Natalie Moses your book must
be your voice best ever playing yes
super excited I don't know if I told you
guys about it maybe I did maybe I didn't
in last week's video i have three days
that I've set aside for recording the
video I'm going to be in a Toronto
studio on three consecutive mondays from
ten a.m. to five or six pm and there's
going to be a producer from
la who's going to be wired in to kind of
listen to me and coach me and tell me
what to do and give advice on how I'm
reading in so I'm super pumped about it
a little worried about my throat and my
voice but but because when I bring it
i'll i want to bring it you know i'm
gonna have fire and energy i'm i don't
if i'm going to sleep the night before
i'm so pumped about goin in it's
actually in a couple weeks thank you
guys for the feedback to one the audible
page doesn't list me as the speaker and
so I wrote to my publisher again asking
for feedback are we through publishers
and hey let's update this see that I'm
going to be the one doing it so yes
super excited super pumped I'm glad you
guys are too for those you order the
audiobook expect some fire to come out
this fire in here but it's gonna be fire
coming out of here is going to be coming
out onto the onto the audio version next
up another one from Natalie the king of
adding value that's the perfect
description of you and this channel I
really appreciate that Natalie that that
means a lot i don't think i would call
myself the king of adding value in my
channel description but I'm really
humbled that you would you would say
that about me it's my hope that at least
fifty percent or if not all your
subscribers eventually buy your book no
matter what the version or they purchase
it for someone else that would find it
super useful that would be amazing we
have 400,000 something subscribers if
fifty percent that's 200,000 people went
out and bought the book that would be
pretty pretty mind-blowing special
amazing spectacular I know not
everybody's in a financial position it's
also not a lot of money for you know one
book I know some people can't afford the
25 book 100 book of our notebook package
but one book you know does mean a lot to
me and and more importantly I think for
you the content in there this isn't just
me trying to cash in there's there's
there's meat in here this this I want to
be one of your favorite books of all
time that there's that level of hustle
energy and love that went into this and
so yes your support does mean a lot to
me I don't also judge like the people
who don't buy it who just consume the
free content I get it and I hope one day
you'll be influenced enough by the
content that it moves you to want to be
curious about the book and pick it up
because the whole reason for all of this
is I truly deeply believe that the
content of that book will dramatically
change your life otherwise I wouldn't be
promoting it
so more important than the thought of
selling two hundred thousand books is
that 200,000 people are going to read
this and have their mind blown and go
off and create amazing things that that
is insanely exciting to me next up
chorea thank you having for
understanding i really like your videos
i would like to support you more buying
your books but right now it's hard for
me i hope one day you showed up my
channel's name because I get it well
choreographic arts you just gotta shout
out there you go and and again I
understand it's not in everybody's
budget and I'm not judging those who
can't afford to get it I do think it's
going to have a big impact on people's
lives on your life I hope one day you
can you can read it and apply the
lessons and super excited to see
Correa's take off once you start
applying those lessons next up is Steven
can't decide whether they get the
physical book the e-book or the
audiobook I'm not much of a physical
book reader although I enjoy the
material possession of it but I read way
more on a device then there's the audio
book which is a little more inconvenient
for me listen to but I really think
Evans energy and passion will give the
words even more weight hmmm excited
either way Steven man and feeling the
love I don't know man it's a tough call
for me I don't buy a lot of books I
don't own a ton of books the ones that I
do keep in terms of a physical copy I
keep in my office and and I like having
a visual I like having a visual that's
there because when I look at it it
reminds me of what that book is about
because if you just read a book and
don't take any action you've just wasted
your time right you've wasted my time
I've written this thing you know I
applying anything I'm pissed you're not
moving forward and so I find that the
books that mean something to me when I
look at them on the shelf and I walk
into my office I'm reminded that yes I
need to continue on like the message
from that book is this and I need to
apply that to my life in my business and
sometimes sparks me reading again or
reading highlights and notes from it so
the books that really moved me the most
I like having a physical copy of just
for that reason I don't read a lot on
the e side of things so that probably
would interest me too much although in
this one it's going to have I want to
say 45 minutes I could be off of bonus
video content
so I would kind of be curious about what
the video I don't know what I don't know
what the video contest and if you guys
have feedback what the video content
should be I'm excited so I'll be curious
of what that video content was and I
don't know if it would move me to want
to buy the e-book but it might and then
I agree with you on the audio side I
don't I don't get a lot of audio stuff
mostly because it sucks like most of the
authors don't read their own stuff I
remember getting I love the art of the
deal by Donald Trump his old book and I
got the audio book and like all ready to
listen to it and some guy trying to be
Donald Trump you know it just doesn't
work like I can't imagine who would try
to be me and if I bought an audiobook
would because I want to hear that person
i bought in some Les Brown programs
where he he goes off and it's like it's
just not the same like reading something
from Les Brown versus hearing him versus
seeing him it's just not the same for me
and so I am going to go into the
recording session channeling fire we
already saw the fire channeling the fire
because it's important like because I
want to move you Stephen who doesn't
usually by audio books to now think
about the extra value that you're
getting I want to move you to wanna buy
it I'm thinking about you Stephen as I
walk into the recording studio spitting
fire for the audiobook I'm probably
gonna come back and read this comment to
myself and have it print it off
somewhere so that I remember so yeah I
don't know if I made your decisions any
easier a tougher there but that's my
take and thank you for your support next
up is Gaius you're the best you're the
best you're the best thank you for that
you're the best that only i want to say
you're doing the best and i love you
even when you post those videos not only
formative but also really interesting
i'm watching a movie in a movie hall I
don't know if you're you're in a movie
hall like in a movie theater now
watching a movie while you posted that
comment I kind of have mixed feelings
because I'm honored that you're watching
movie but you'd rather be watching my
videos that makes me feel good but I
also really hate it when somebody's on
their phone well I'm trying to enjoy a
movie so I'm conflicted I don't know I
don't know what I feel about that what
do you guys think is this a celebration
she would be happy
trooper tree we be advocating this
watching my youtube channel in the movie
theater while the movies happening it's
a tough one you guys let me know leave a
comment down below and last up is mel
mel sorry i haven't watched in awhile
been preoccupied with other things
listen you know I really appreciate all
support you guys give me I make a habit
of watching the videos on my channel not
just because it's my channel and I care
deeply about the content i'm creating
but because i need it for myself for me
to grow to learn to be inspired to get
ideas to want to go off and do something
if for example i'll be away i know i'm
away for a long weekend or something and
then I batch everything earlier so that
I've watched all the videos and I don't
have to worry about it for a weekend I
will miss it like I'll feel a little
deflated you know yeah I had a great
time being away but i but i miss the chi
Chi need the content i'm like i'm i i'm
addicted to the content i need to have
it and so you know the most important
thing for me is that you're watching the
content but then applying it right like
I don't just watch the content just only
because I'm addicted to it I'm addicted
to the the growth that comes from it
from the thinking and the application in
how I'm going to make my businesses and
my life and the relationships I have
better because of the content the ideas
and inspiration is what really i'm
addicted to and I need constantly but
the videos themselves the book itself
means nothing if you're not applying it
so mel mel i would much rather you watch
one video a week and then be off
applying the lessons in that and watch
every single video and just be a
consumer and not actually create
anything right at some point you guys
have to move from being consumers to
being creators you don't add value by
just consuming we got value by making
your own thing and you can consume with
the goal to help you make something
better so if i'm one of the few channels
that you subscribe to when you
consistently watch content I'm honored
I'm humbled if you watch a video a month
and that means helping to you that's
awesome too if you're watching every
video I appreciate that too but most
important is that you are applying the
lessons and you're off doing something
powerful and meaningful with your
business and your life so that's all I
got for you guys today again back to the
topic I would love your feedback on our
landing
page it's Evan Carmichael calm / one
word check it out let me know what you
think what what makes sense what does it
make sense where should we improve we
put a lot of love into it but the busy
seasons coming up and so I want to make
sure that it's ready to go everything
makes sense for you guys so please leave
a comment let me know what you think I
also wanted to give a quick shadow to
Vladimir Safco who bought one copy of
the book and then three more copies of
the audiobook to gift to friends really
appreciate that I think it's an amazing
gift you can give people as well and you
can especially if you can read it read
through it together and be able to push
each other and talk to each other and
have like little book club around that
maybe we should do some book clubs or
form our own book club Vladimir you got
me thinking anyway Thank You Vladimir so
much for you guys watching you want your
chance at a shout out in the future
video make sure to pick up a copy email
in your receipts don't forget some you
guys are not emailing in we can't keep
track we can't give you the bonuses all
that stuff emailing your seats thank you
guys so much for all your support all
your love it really means a lot to me
looking forward to seeing you soon I'll
see you in the next video I'll see you
next week continue to believe or
whatever your one word is unless you see